So the correct answer is the second one. So hopefully, no one picked
the first answer. We usually do try to do things the easy way.
There is sort of an exception to that in this whole unit. That
we're learning ourselves how to define a hash table. Even though Python provides
a dictionary type, which I'll talk about at the very end of the
unit. That makes things much easier than what we're doing ourselves, but we
really want to understand a lot of computer science by building our own hash
table, and then we won't actually need to use it because there's a built-in
type that works much better. But the answer is
the second answer, and here's the reason why. So what
happens when we evaluate this list multiplication, well, we have
this empty list, let's draw it like this. And we
create a new list, which is three copies of that
list. But it's not copies, it's three references to it.
So here's the new list. It has three elements. Each
one of those elements refers to the same empty list.
Then when we did table index 1 append, well, what
happened is we follow this reference to whatever table index
1 is, this object we appended to it, added a
new element. But because the references at position zero, one, and
two, all refer to the same object, that changed all
of those values, not just the value of table index 1.
And we can see that if we print out the
whole table, that the table contains three elements. But they're all
the same. And they all refer to the same object.
So any change we make to one changes all of them.